[Music]
Then,
instead of this red one, it sounds like milk. I chose this color for the milk
.  I don't think so
[music]
Part of the mystery has been solved huh The owner of the
footprints punched Mizushima and
disappeared in the mirror
.
It's not like the culprit got in the tangle This is
after stepping on the milk here and stepping back
And who is the owner of the footprint The answer is literally
this  Now that Mizushima is holding it, both hands are full
.
Last night, Mizushima abandoned me and decided to go to sleep alone, and when I left, I
was breastfeeding the trio in front of the mirror.
It's Mizushima's, isn't it? Well, wow, it's been a long time since you
've been breeding so far, so why did you suddenly join me
?
masato I understand.
I'll give Dora a body
and legs that can
withstand a
salty lake
.